in 1995 three doctors quit their jobs to
make a videogame they had no game
development experience had recently
graduated med school and $100,000
between them this modest startup was
none other than Bioware the studio
behind later games such as Mass Effect
Knights of the Old Republic and of
course
Baldur's Gate
when Bioware was founded computer
role-playing games were in a bit of a
dry spell young development talent was
geared toward first-person shooters and
real-time strategy games in the late 90s
leveraging the improved graphics at the
time RPGs were abundant in the console
space with Chrono Cross Xenogears and
the Final Fantasy games still going
strong but aside from Diablo in 1996 and
the original fallout two years after
that
Baldur's Gate was an anomaly an RPG
created for the computer crowd inspired
by the pen and paper games Bioware
members had grown up with yet looking
back it's held as one of the games that
saved computer RPGs it exemplified
player freedom fluid storylines and an
interconnected world cut to 2000 and we
have Baldur's Gate 2 shadows of aam it
expanded on the tenets of its
predecessor in nearly every way it made
Bioware a household name for PC players
I still remember the first time I played
it like many I was entranced by its
complex setting its memorable storyline
it's phenomenal side quests and depth of
strategy I still remember a de LAN the
dragon and John irenic hissed the
villain
I still remember replaying the game as
soon as I finished it and just recently
I picked up divinity original sin 2 and
like many I can't help but see the
similarities between this game and
Baldur's Gate 2 both are sequels that
expand on their predecessors in nearly
every way both reward your imagination
both are masterpieces and both actually
encourage role-playing something the
genre has ironically lacked on many
occasions in the past decade
you can point to something like Mass
Effect or Dragon Age Origins games where
you create a hero and build them toward
a variety of set endings based on
choices you make along the way you
oftentimes decide to be good or evil
heroic or villainous and these games are
very good at doing so but that's the
thing these games are often centered
around binary choices do you follow the
Paragon route and spare the Solarians
life or do you follow the renegade path
plunging the galaxy into chaos at every
turn
[Music]
there's a definite dichotomy to the
decisions you're making whether the game
makes any attempt to hide it or not the
best moments of modern RPGs are Sophie's
Choice scenarios situations when you
have to sacrifice one character to spare
another or when you have to choose
between the good of the many or the more
emotional good of the few they're not
based on some concrete morality meter
but rather which characters ideal is
aligned with yours or which soldier will
be most useful in the grand scheme of
things don't be afraid
[Music]
[Applause]
there she is Burma foul which no one is
burning anyone friends let me put it
this way these types of games give you
chaotic worlds that you must then
introduce order to whether that be
through heroic deeds evil acts or some
blend of the two your choices have
specific effects on the world your story
is branching in many directions but
there are only a few real endings you
can arrive at another example is The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt its side quests
explore the politics racism and fear of
a fantasy world murdering a king could
come back to bite you down the road
supporting one character's ascent to
political office could have unforeseen
effects in the future it constantly
presents you with chaos and asks you to
make sense of it all divinity original
sin - on the other hand does things
differently in fact it almost does the
exact opposite it gives you an orderly
world with concrete rules and asks you
to be the agent of chaos you can kill
anyone you want recruit anyone you want
betray anyone you want original sin - is
brilliant not because it presents you
with specific choices to make but
because it lets you create the choices
yourself my undead character bleaker
encounters a clairvoyant lizard who can
help me escape from prison he can also
help my friend the red Prince regain his
throne he also has beef with my elf
companions Sabeel both of my comrades
want to talk to the lizard in private
away from prying ears in a lesser game
this might be a simple matter of right
or wrong good or bad but I just met this
lizard and I don't know what kind of
ruler the Prince would make down the
road and Sabeel just stuck a needle in
my neck only hours ago should I play it
safe and focus on escaping or allow my
friend some time alone with the NPC the
game can branch in dozens of directions
at this point but it's a superb
role-playing game because in my mind the
choice is much more complicated than it
needs to be
that's because true to the genres name
I'm role-playing I created my skeletal
character with a threatening ravenous
zombie warrior in mind what I failed to
consider was that my morbid appearance
would make normal everyday conversations
difficult for me so of course I put a
bucket on my head problem solved but of
course now I look like an idiot
and idiots don't make the most
threatening heroes from there on out I
saw my character as a bumbling underdog
who means
but can't help providing comic relief at
every turn in fact I fell so deeply into
this character that when he missed an
easy shot or accidentally lit his
teammates on fire it made sense in a
super dumb kind of way and it was okay
this world is so vast and interconnected
and dense I can always find another way
to make things work I think that's the
heart that pumps vitality into every one
of Divinity's systems its world
influences your choices and not the
other way around the fascinating
byproduct of this is that I don't always
have a solid idea of who my character
actually is and if you'll allow me to be
dramatic here for a second isn't that
usually how things go in the real world
how often do we as humans make mistakes
or out of character choices or poor
judgment calls how often do we do
something stupid and can't do much but
live with the consequences Larry ins RPG
is remarkable in the way that actually
encourages mistakes and I think that's
the secret here by allowing for
coincidence and accidents original sin -
makes your deliberate choices all that
much more powerful knowing that things
could fall apart at any moment makes it
all that much more special when you're
holding them together and when you
inevitably screw up divinity is right
there to say it's okay
[ __ ] happens try to make the best of it
try to build something from the ashes
you'll inevitably load previous saves
throughout the game and in a computer
RPG I highly encourage you to do so but
this game is at its best when you roll
with the punches like pillars of
eternity and torment tides of numenera
original sin - continues the legacy of
baldur's gate - and the pen and paper
games that inspired it they're games
that actually encourage role-playing
they allow you to imagine a character
yes but they also encourage you to
reconsider that character along a way to
play a role but to also toy with it to
target the strings and watch the entire
thing unravel in the most magnificent
way
[Music]
you